[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday kicking off sky
news's live coverage of cop 26 here in
glasgow
boyce johnson usually the life and soul
of the party told world leaders
gathering in rome yesterday that in the
fight against man-made climate change
humanity is 5-1 down and it isn't even
half time yet
his gloom may be down to the absence of
some star players china and russia's
leaders haven't made it to the game this
week
and some other fossil fuel stars
australia saudi arabia amongst them
don't look as though they'll deliver
their net zero goals until 2060.
in short it's seven years since the
governments
who jubilantly signed the paris accord
agree to try to halt the rise in global
temperature
yet today we are no closer to that
objective
can glasgow pull the irons out of the
fire
we'll see what our guests hope for this
morning
in a moment i'll be joined by the
president designate the man uh the
government has asked to lead this huge
endeavor uh alec sharma
i'll get a sense of the extraordinary
risk we face from climate change both in
the future and happening right now
with tina steady who is climate envoy
for the marshall islands a pacific
nation which is one of the world's most
threatened countries
we'll find out how the uk is doing from
the body that marks the government's
homework on
hitting net zero by 2050 i'll speak to
the chair of the climate change
committee lord devon
with some of the world's most powerful
leaders already negotiating at g20 we'll
go live to rome and speak to former
european commission president uh jose
manuel barroso and we'll also get
labour's take on cop from shadow
international trade secretary emily
thornbury
and we'll end today with an exclusive
and rare interview with the equalities
minister i sat down with kobe bad-knock
to mark the end of black history month
today we touched on trans rights and the
kathleen stock controversy too
first though in just a couple of hours
time the government's point man on cop
will be formally elected as president
here in glasgow it's quite an
extraordinary responsibility and must
come with pressure to match with the
eyes and quite probably the hopes of the
world on what happens here over the next
two weeks that man is alok sharma and he
joins me now
good morning president designate um
the un
says that without fresh targets uh on
the or progress we've made until now we
certainly aren't going to limit the rise
in global surface temperature to 1.5 in
fact
they're talking this week of a forecast
of 2.7
degrees you're gonna need to get some
new measures out of the next two weeks
to hit the 1.5 target that you've talked
about well trevor this is obviously a
very big tough ass that we've got here
in glasgow but i think it's worth
reflecting on where we've got to so
before paris uh analysts suggested that
we were heading towards six degrees of
global warming after paris that uh
temperature curve was bent downwards
under four degrees and actually if you
look at the uh un
report that you're referring to and of
course the international energy agency
report that suggests that if you take
all the commitments that have been made
by governments we have bent the curve
towards two degrees so there has been
progress for the last few years but you
know i would say that actually the task
we have here is in many ways tougher
than paris paris was a a brilliant
achievement a historic achievement but
it was a framework agreement what we've
had to do since then is to agree some of
the detailed rules and some of the most
difficult rules are still outstanding
after six years that makes it really
challenging and of course we know that
the geopolitics is more difficult than
it was at the time of paris well let's
come to some of that but
you say that uh you know we've made
progress actually looking at what
countries have done
i think
we reckon that of the 35 most important
countries only the gambia has hit its
paris accord agreement
are you going to start by essentially
laying down the law
to uh the
the parties here that basically they
haven't done what they said they would
do in paris well trevor you're right i
mean this is on world leaders at the end
of the day and uh they made the
commitments in paris that we would limit
temperature rises to well below degrees
pursuing efforts to 1.5 and now in
glasgow they have to deliver you know
we've got the g20 ongoing right now and
those world leaders will arrive here
tomorrow for the world leaders summit
and my message to them is very clear
leave the ghosts of the pass behind you
it is halloween today after all but
leave the ghost of the past behind you
and let's focus on the future and unite
around this one issue that we know
matters for all of us which is
protecting our precious planet your
colleague prime minister is not very
optimistic
um
he said to the u.n a month ago when
kermit the frog sang it's not easy being
green i want you to know he was wrong i
invite you in november to celebrate what
i hope will be a coming of age and to
blow out the candles of a world on fire
classic johnson boosterism this week he
said it's going to be very very tough
this summit and i'm very worried because
it might go wrong it's touch and go it's
very very difficult it's very far from
clear that we'll get the progress that
we need what happened in the weeks in
between those two statements well the
premise is absolutely right it is going
to be really really tough at this summit
and we've got two weeks to get this over
the line but he was also making the
point that
when we took on the presidency of cop 26
less than 30 percent of the global
economy was covered by a net zero target
we're now at over 80 percent almost all
the g20 nations that we're talking about
have got a net zero target for the
middle of the century if i had come onto
this program a year ago trevor and i
said that to you you would have been
really skeptical so there has been
progress but there's much more but we're
talking promises here aren't we and
actually part of what you've got to do
in the next couple of weeks is arm
wrestle people into some new promises
now it's not that helpful that president
xi
uh president putin aren't turning up i
mean basically they're saying
honestly
we're not that bothered
well if you have a look at what uh both
president putin president xi have
actually announced they both announced
uh net zero targets for the middle of
the century
one promises that haven't met the first
law well well if i may and of course the
world leader summit is really important
we've got over 120 world leaders coming
from you know all over the globe but of
course what we're also going to have is
two weeks of detailed negotiations and
those teams are here i've met uh with
some of the representatives from russia
from china over the last few days i've
been doing the sort of pre-prep for crop
for cop itself and so um that is what's
going to be really important is to get
over the line these key negotiation
issues as well and this is a chance
quite frankly for all of these countries
to show leadership this is the point
where they have to stand up and be
counted do you want more out of china
and russia than they have promised i
want more out of every country but i
think the point here is that we have
made progress and then we're going to
have to take stock of where there is a
gap in you know what the commitments are
and where we need to be and one of the
things we're going to have to discuss in
a very consensus-led way is how do we
close that gap over this decisive decade
and you know some people are suggesting
we need to come back and look at those
commitments again those 20 30
commitments over the next couple of
years that is an agreement that's going
to come through consensus and it's my
job to help build that consensus what
are you going to do about the saudis and
the australians both of whom are
basically saying
fine we'll try and do what we can we'll
we'll plant some trees and so on but we
are absolutely not going to reduce
production of uh
oil in saudi's case and australia's case
before 2030 and that is going to stymie
your aim isn't it well both those
countries have committed to net zero by
the middle of the century and of course
the pressure is on on them as it is on
every country to set out precisely how
they will do that and that's why we have
been asking for countries to set out
their long-term strategies for getting
to net zero the uk as you know in the
last few days has published its own uh
net series strategy which has been
welcomed by very many seen as a a
benchmark a global benchmark which
others can look at as well so you know
my ask is of every country come forward
with the detailed policies which will
deliver on the commitments that you've
made you mentioned the uk um
the chancellor this week reduced
airport
duty taxes he's made flying domestically
easier has he apologized yet for
undermining your credibility well
actually have you if you look at what
the chancellor has announced he's
announced very many billions of pounds
of support uh to further our plan for a
green industrial revolution
let me let me address that that issue so
domestic aviation represents less than
one percent of our emissions in 2019 and
remember as a country over the last 30
years we've cut our emissions by over 40
percent and you need to see this
alongside the fact that we are investing
in sustainable aviation fuels we've got
a jet zero program
and of course there is an issue of
connectivity uh where because we are an
island
you can't get that easily from one part
to the other which isn't the case for
every country are we going to come out
of here in two weeks with a deal of some
kind
that is what i'm driving towards and i
think what i've always said is that what
we need to come from out of glasgow is
to be able to say with credibility that
we have kept 1.5 alive and i know you've
got others on this program and that 1.5
really matters we know from the ipcc
that we're already at global warming of
1.1 degree above pre-industrial levels
at 1.5 there are countries in the world
that will be underwater and that's why
we need to get an agreement here on how
we tackle climate change over the next
decade indeed we're going to address
exactly that point in a moment but for
the moment thank you very much alex
sharma president designate of cop 26.
thank you
now for many parts of the world climate
change is not tomorrow's problem it's a
reality today
that's the case in the pacific nation of
the marshall islands it's one of the
first countries in the world to be
severely affected
rising sea levels are expected to put 40
percent of all buildings in the nation's
capital maduro at risk with 96 of the
city at risk of frequent flooding
i'm joined now by the country's climate
envoy tina steady
good morning miss steady um
trevor
what are your expectations out of cop 26
what do you want to see
at the end of the two weeks here
i want us to come out with an agreement
that keeps 1.5 in reach it's absolutely
the line for us if we go past it the
future is really quite unimaginable
i want to see that we have support
and solidarity on particularly
adaptation issues for my country
living with 1.1 is a challenge living
with 1.5 is going to be very painful and
we're going to need to adapt in
transformative ways and we're going to
need
support to do that and so we really need
to see in addition finance there's got
to be resources for the most vulnerable
to do what needs to be done to stay
a part of this global community
when you say support and you're talking
essentially now about money
the rich countries had promised to put
together a fund of i think 100 billion
dollars um
it's not entirely clear how far they've
got with this but it doesn't sound like
they've even got into double figures yet
does that
inspire much trust in you that they're
taking this seriously i'll be really
frank it's it's it's a huge
disappointment it's
it's very difficult uh when you're told
that
resources are putting in are being put
in place and and to not to not see that
happen
there has been a a plan delivered and
there's been a lot of work done to say
how we will get there
and we're going to continue working with
our partners to make sure that that in
fact happens but we also need to think
beyond
2025 what is going to be the finance
goal beyond that and those talks start
at this cop and we need all of our
partners to to support us to ensure that
we're going to address this problem at
the scale
that is required
the you said earlier on this month that
uh you thought the key to progress
actually lay not
here but in the g20
um are you hearing anything from rome
that gives you any encouragement
done as much as we can do to try to
send the message
alongside some of our partners my
president signed a letter alongside the
prime minister of denmark and
ireland's leader and several others to
really send the message to the g20 that
look the major emitters this group you
have the key you can keep 1.5 in sight
if you just put in those concrete
policies and actions that we all need
now in this critical decade
and
i am still waiting to see what's coming
out of that meeting i've heard both some
positive and and some really challenging
things i think we know that this is
going to be a very tough two weeks
and um
i just can't let up hope because failure
is really not an option for my country
what um bring it to life for us what
would be the consequences for your
country if that 1.5
degree target isn't met
i have to tell you
beyond 1.5 is unimaginable for for my
country we are um an atoll nation that
sits just two meters above sea level
i don't know if what if you know what
that means um two meters is
it's a it's an a nation of coastline
we don't even have hills trevor so
we're looking at sea level rise of 0.5
meters
at 1.5
and as you said that means inundations
yearly inundations we need to start
thinking about how to raise land
buildings how are we going to survive in
that 1.5 world so beyond 1.5 we cannot
go
so
the situation you're describing in a way
suggests that um
if we don't fix this
uh
in 50 years time what we now call a
martial island as a state will be
history i can't accept that outcome that
that's not acceptable to me and i don't
think it should be acceptable to any
person or nation in this world to write
off a country
and what i keep telling partners is
we're on the front lines we're on the
front of the front lines we are the most
vulnerable
but if you protect the most vulnerable
you protect yourself and you protect
your children
and i think we've really learned if
anything from covid
if you protect the front line everyone
is protected
we were speaking briefly before and uh i
was saying my family comes from
guyana which is um
not entirely below uh sea level but the
the most um densely inhabited parts of
the country lie 20 feet below school uh
below sea level and i'm thinking as
you're speaking that actually if it were
not for the sea wall um the school that
i went to
would actually be under water
is it do you think that there is
actually
realistically the possibility of
protecting countries like this
or is it just now too late
it can't be too late and we're working
on a national adaptation plan which we
call our survival plan
and
we have to have hope for our future i'm
not consigning
our future to history that's not a
choice
our choice is to work and to fight to
make sure
that we have
safety and security for my children and
for my children's children
that's going to be a different reality
it's going to be a transformed reality
we see that
but we don't accept
that reality means no future
what are you saying to alex sharma
that
success will look like for you in two
weeks time what what concretely do you
want to see him
delivering
in two weeks time
we need the cop presidency
president to start us out with very high
ambition at this cop we need to have
processes that
make sure
we understand there is a gap how are we
meeting that gap there
we're not going to make 1.5 if we're not
going to make it at this cup how can we
keep it on the table that has to be our
guiding star
in addition we need to understand what
are we going to do to make sure that
we're looking at adaptation how are we
going to help those the most vulnerable
like my country to actually live in this
present that that we're looking at now
and we also need to see the resources
that
you know we're going to have the finance
to be able to adapt and
secure our future
tina thank you so much indeed now that
we'll be talking to you again on sky
news thanks so much trevor thank you
[Music]
now if that is a consequence of climate
change happening right now
can we
limit its impact and if so how
well that's what this conference is
supposed to be all about countries
committing to
how they're going to reduce their
emissions all with the goal of keeping
global increase
in average temperatures to 1.5 degrees
centigrade since the industrial
revolution
the united kingdom says it will get to
zero carbon emissions by 2050 and the
climate change committee tells us how
we're getting on its chair the former
environment secretary lord dieben joins
me now
good good morning lord demon
um
good morning
how are we getting on do you think 1.5
degrees is actually
um is actually
uh
attainable
yes i do um and not only do i think it's
attainable but i very much agree with
your last uh interviewee
uh it has to be uh attainable because
it's not just uh the marshall islands or
those that would disappear were it not
to be attained but as she says behind
them are very many other communities
places like bangladesh which are
entirely beneath the
sea level
large parts of the united states and of
europe
where
great cities will be losing very large
sections
all that we have to defend
and uh it's uh i'm afraid
a battle which we just have to win it's
like in that sense the battle of britain
we cannot possibly lose it
does the fact that we we are missing
some of the big players here in glasgow
president xi president putin president
bolsonaro
is that going to make a difference to
what can come out of this uh this event
well
it'd be much better if they were there
although i'm not sure president
bolsonaro would uh raise the standard
much but the fact of the matter is that
uh in the end
these countries are going to be just as
affected and i'm very interested to see
that the
chinese are moving all the time because
they actually believe in climate change
they understand what huge damage it's
doing to their own country and
president xi has already made a number
of steps it's not good enough yet but
they've committed to net zero
and they've um
made it clear that they're not now going
to support
the production of coal-fired power
stations outside their own land and they
are increasing the amount of in a huge
way the amount of offshore wind and and
solar that they're installing and we
have to remember that their emissions
are our emissions i mean we have
exported our manufacturer to china and
we are buying those goods so this is an
issue which we can't entirely shovel off
to them
um
the the president designates uh
alexander is not not a person who um
let's put its way puts his emotions out
there but he seemed to me talking to him
a little earlier
rather frustrated by the fact that what
we seem to get again and again is a lot
of promises from these countries but not
always the action that he would like
how
can he make sure that um the next two
weeks aren't just uh in the words of
greta tonberg a lot of blah blah blah
well i mean this is one of the big
problems isn't it the the british
government i must say and i have
certainly not been a uh
undoubted supporter of it the british
government has taken the step which
everyone has to take which is to turn
its commitments into the first step of a
net zero
program and the climate change committee
is going to keep the government's feet
to the fire we've also made it statutory
we have to do it by law so that the
government can be held to account in the
courts so we have done those things i'd
quite agree there are some other things
we shouldn't have done which
hadn't helped but that we have done and
those are the things which we've got to
see from other nations in their own way
in their own systems but in a way which
we know is really going to deliver
is one of the things that our government
should not have done is to reduce uh
airport taxes to make in order to make
domestic
flights uh less expensive
well i'm afraid the government is hung
up in trying to prove
that leaving the european union was a
good idea
and that's quite difficult and so one of
the things it can do is to reduce the
taxes internally and not across the
whole of europe so it decides to do that
actually it doesn't make any difference
as a matter of technicality because the
way that internal flights are accounted
for under climate change will mean that
they'll just have to pay more in carbon
so it's not carbon tax so actually it's
not going to make all that difference
but it was perhaps not the right thing
to do i think it's less important
than remembering that they have
increased the cost of long
haul flights
and remembering also that the biggest
mistake that was made was to cut our
overseas aid from 0.7 to 0.5 which
doesn't give people confidence that
we're going to help people in the way
we've promised to do and that for me was
a really deeply immoral and unacceptable
act
it sounds to me lord that what you're
saying is that in spite of uh our own
governments
i'm afraid to let use that phrase again
blah blah blah the action that follows
is at least um
neutral it isn't necessarily uh pointing
in the direction that you uh want to
want the government to to go in terms of
uh
improving the prospects of getting to
1.5 degrees essentially what you're
saying is
government says it says it's going to do
the right thing but actually
in what it does
it's heading in the wrong direction
now i don't agree with that at all i
haven't said that i've said it's made
mistakes but then every government does
this is the one government that says
nothing but electric cars or the
equivalent after 2030. this is the
government that has an actual strategy
to reach net zero and a policy and
program to do it this is the government
that's made that legally binding this is
the first government to sign up to net
zero in 2050. this is a government that
has got a policy for building and
heating in in its own country which no
other government has this is a
government which is out on the front
line and is doing the right things which
every now and again makes mistakes and
one of the problems with the press is
that we hear very
much too little thank you for getting
bits right and always concentrating
things get wrong now my trouble is that
i'm the chairman of the climate change
committee and my job is to keep the
government feet to the fire and make
sure that it goes on doing the right
things and avoids doing the wrong things
but it doesn't mean that i don't respect
the fact that this government has
committed itself in a way which no other
government has and parliament has
supported it whereas joe biden for
example has rejoined the world in this
remarkable way but he's having terrible
trouble getting his own legislator to
give him the support that we need if
we're going to stop the world from
disaster and disaster it is don't
undercut i don't undermine this this is
a
one chance we have to save the world
i get i get that uh and you say
this is the government that's done this
this and this well let's take one
example electric cars yup they've made a
pledge on electric cars but i think your
own committee says uh that we've got 26
000 charging uh points we really need
450 000 now
is there any possibility
that we're actually going to hit that
in time
well i've been lucky enough to have an
electric car as a matter of fact and all
i can tell you is that the advance in
the charging arrangements are is
enormous and i have had no trouble at
all using it uh my problem is that we've
got to move to a situation in which
those cars are within the
ability of everyone to buy as against uh
petrol cars and the biggest change
sorry i don't want to interrupt you but
um my car one of my colleagues here at
sky tried to drive from did drive from
london to glasgow and what he discovered
is that one in ten charging points even
of the 26 000 at any given time isn't
working we really haven't got the
infrastructure to deliver
well with i mean
i don't want to be put into a position
of defending the government because i'm
not i'm an independent and i don't
defend the government okay and the
government could do a great deal more
all i'm saying is that in the context of
the world this government has been doing
a great deal
my job is to make sure that it does more
and more and on the charging front there
is a great deal more to be done not
least to making it easier to have a
charge because unfortunately they're run
by different people with different
mechanisms and that's barmy so we have
to put that right and the truth is that
some motor cars uh have been made by
people who've made better provision and
we've got to think about how we have uh
superchargers for everybody they're
they're all those things that need to be
done the government is
on the way to doing that and our job is
not to say you haven't done it yet it is
to say that we want more now we want
more next month than we want more the
month after and you've got to meet the
target which the climate change
committee has set
lord demon thank you very much i really
appreciate your time well thank you
now world leaders those that are coming
including president biden will gather
here tomorrow
but many of the most powerful are
already in rome for the g20 meeting
there
negotiations are already well underway
and some on some of the thorniest issues
here at cop along with talks on covid
and the global economy
joining me now is the former european
commission president and the gavi chair
the
international vaccine organization chair
jose manuel barroso
good morning mr barroso
i wonder if we could start with covid um
we are hearing a great deal from
developing countries right now
that
the vaccination rates are still too low
particularly in africa
and there is a complaint that
vaccines that are on the shelves in rich
countries are just sitting there when
they could be used
in developing countries gordon brown the
former prime minister says that a
hundred million
doses will expire that could be useful
where are we on all of that
uh we are in a situation of unacceptable
inequity in fact
uh there is a huge difference between
the situation of vaccination in the
developed world
including united states or europe
and let's say africa and especially the
low-income countries that are at
shocking
uh levels um low levels of vaccination
and precisely one of the goals i was
expecting from this g20 and i had a
pleasure to meet some weeks ago uh mario
draghi
who is as you know prime minister of
italy and the current chair in office of
g20 was to have some more clear
determination more ambition on putting
an end to the critical phase of this um
pandemic and i'm not yet sure we are
going to attain that objective with that
in spite of the great efforts i have to
say of mario draghi himself and the very
competent italian presidency
that sounds extremely disappointing i
mean
the are you saying that the
world leaders just really can't agree to
send vaccinations to places where it's
needed
rather than letting them expire in
places where it's not needed
the delays are due to several causes
first of all there were and there still
are export restrictions there was also
the holding the accumulation of too many
vaccines in the richer countries and so
there was less vaccines for poorer
countries
as a chair of gavi i'm part of kovacs
it's the global facility for a global
immunization and we have seen that so
there was priority given by
manufacturers to the rich countries so
what they are now asking the rich
countries is precisely to swap the line
so that you can reach the the smaller i
mean the smaller economies
so
that has been partly compensated i want
to be fair
um these problems have been partly
compensated by
very generous donations namely from the
united states also from europe
and also by generous financing but the
reality is
that we continue to have a shameful
situation of unacceptable inequity and
one of the problems is precisely that
when there are donations they are given
very late so with little shelf time it's
very close to the expiry dates and
without
sufficient advance notice which makes it
extremely difficult from a logistical
point of view because do not forget that
this is the biggest ever operation of
global vaccination we never had anything
comparable in history so it makes very
difficult to reach those that we want to
reach namely in the low-income countries
you just won't use the word shameful
um
others might say it's shocking that uh
i understand all the issues and the
bureaucracy and so on and so forth but
you were there during the financial
crisis and part of the point of what
happened during that period was that
world leaders gathered in order to cut
through
that sort of bureaucracy and those rules
how is it possible
that when people are dying unnecessarily
that cannot happen now
that's a very important political
question and if you
if you want i can compare the situation
because i was in all those g20 summits
between 2008 until the end of my second
mandate in european commission uh 2014
and uh in fact there was a much higher
level of cooperation than than today
um i i had that privilege of being in
the first it was in washington the
second was in london with gordon brown
precisely
the third was in again in the united
states at obama
and at that time
if you want to be frank it was
unthinkable some of the world leaders
not to come in person to those
summits so i'm afraid
and i'm measuring my words
i'm afraid that the current geopolitical
participation
the current geopolitical friction
is having a negative impact
in the global cooperation
and also in the level of ambition when
it comes to uh fight for global public
goods like public health or like climate
action so and this is a problem
i understand that it we have also
because of the
let's say tensions between united states
and china we are watching some kind of
decoupling
namely technology and i believe
personally that it's almost unavoidable
but i would not like to see
that decoupling when it comes to fight
for global public goods like fighting
this terrible pandemic or fighting
climate change in spite of the
differences of the regimes the political
regimes and they are serious and very
profound
i think it makes sense that united
states china europe russia india
of course in europe i am also including
the uk european indian and uk that we
all work for these global public goods
and i can tell you from experience that
today the atmosphere the political
understanding and level of
cooperation is clearly below what was
before when we saw the financial crisis
well um you
coupled in that answer covid tackling
covert and also climate change well
we're here at glasgow for cop
and your point about uh
absent leaders president xi president
putin
means that
from what you just said we've almost
already lost the battle haven't we
because they are not coming
they have said what they're going to do
their net zero goals are 2060 rather
than 2050 or earlier which is what's
need what uh the
the un thinks is needed so
actually
um
we are in a place where these tensions
that you refer to
are have actually already frustrated the
possibility of
reaching 1.5 and rescuing places like
the marshall islands
i don't want to be
too pessimistic let's see what the
results are as we know beside before
this summit usually there is
uh some lowering of expectations usually
the compromises come very close to the
end
and it's true that both president xi and
president putin presented some reasons
not to come
but
i have to say if i want to be frank that
i'm skeptic
about the capacities to reach the goals
that we would like to see not only for
the glasgow cop26 but for the future
i'm skeptic because um
in fact uh when i compare once again
with what we have done before uh
european union and first at that time uk
was part of the european union i can
tell you that uk was one of the leaders
inside the european union for more
ambition with climate change namely tony
blair and other leaders afterwards
i think we have been doing a little i
mean showing real leadership there but
other parts of the world they are not
translating those commitments in
legislation so i need to see them
translated in legislation and also it is
not clear how to give either how to
achieve those goals so it's not just to
proclaim aspirational goals okay it's
better to do that than not to do it but
how to reach those goals this is not
clear so i think um the scrutiny
of the results has to be
in terms of commitments to legislate on
those methods but also in terms of the
concrete path to reach these goals this
is uh you know the real test now
afterwards in terms of language
it's not yet the final the communique
here i'm speaking to you from rome it's
not it's a good language i mean it's the
the words
but but i think it lacks all right
precise commitments
mr mr just very briefly i mean you're a
veteran of these things you've seen them
over
decades what do you think the chances
are i don't know if you're a betting man
what do you think the chances are
of getting anything meaningful out of
this as opposed to what the
young activists call blah blah blah
i would say 50 50
to trying to be optimistic
um 50 50. i i still believe it's
important and at least
to to make an effort
but um this will take time
let's be honest about it okay we'll not
be solving uh all the problems but i
believe it's possible and certainly we
are going the right direction but not at
the speed we need
mr barroso thank you very much indeed
for your time this morning thank you
now let's get the view from her
majesty's loyal opposition now
emily thornbury is labour's shadow
secretary of state for international
trade and she joins me
good morning trevor
good morning mrs thornbury now um i
don't know if you heard uh alex sharma
earlier on but he seemed rather
frustrated by the run-up to
cop 26 and the the fact that uh we don't
really seem to be sure what's going to
come out of this how hopeful are you
i met uh 500 plus delegates at uh some
pancreas yesterday um who were going to
cop and lots of young people and they
were so enthusiastic and so optimistic
um and so positive i can't help that
rubbing off on me
um
but then the politician in me stops and
we look and we see
you know we had a commitment in paris to
keep to 1.5 so we have this ambition but
we see we don't seem to have the plans
the backfill you know how are we
actually going to get there and what we
need at the end of this cop meeting is
for countries to have plans on the table
that we can look at that we can
scrutinize we can hold them to account
and we can say okay the amount of carbon
your country is producing um
collectively with all the other
countries in the world will not take us
above 1.5 and we're such a long way from
that
mr barroso was rather skeptical about
the reasons given by the chinese
president the russian president for not
showing up um
are you equally skeptical and do you
think it matters
well all that matters in the end is that
each country has a plan to get down to
net zero in a timely way
um you know getting there by 2060 is
probably is too late but i think as
important as when you get to net zero
is how much carbon you're producing on
your way down
and you know many countries seem to have
committed to getting to net zero but we
don't really have the plans from them as
to how it is that they're going to get
there
and that's as important as anything else
so whether people pitch up or whether
people don't pitch up i mean this is not
a kind of
i don't know
you know this is not just a sort of you
know a lap of honor for for countries
going there needs to be serious work
and my concern i if i'm being really
honest and brutal about this is that
quite often before these summits happen
a great deal of hard work has been done
and you know countries have got quite a
long way to the agreement before you get
the final uh agreement at the meeting
itself and my concern is that there's
still so much work to be done at glasgow
that
you know that a particular leader
turning up or not is not by itself going
to make a difference
the united nations says that
on current trends we are not going to
make it to 1.5
in fact they talk a bit more about
two plus and maybe even 2.7 degrees
what would the
labor government have done that the
current government
has not done
okay
right the first thing we would have done
was that we would have as i've already
alluded to we would need to be making
sure that we were doing really serious
negotiations for a much longer period
than this government has done and had
much more much more grip we would have
had to focus on it much more than we
have done um i know that alex sharma has
done his best but frankly it is a
failure of our ability to be able to
bring countries together that we haven't
got more agreement before now number one
number two we would be showing
leadership by example we would not be
having a budget in which we were
suddenly cutting taxes on internal
flights you know we would not be cutting
back on the amount of money that was
available to invest in the developed
world because we've cut back 0.7 and so
there is not the money going into the
developed world in the way that we need
to we need to be putting money into the
developed world in order to help them to
get to net zero and also to help protect
them against the effects of climate
change which is already happening what
else would we be doing so we would be
properly negotiating we'll be leading by
example we would be looking after the
most vulnerable we would be making sure
that the action made by this government
would have we would look to to to
measure action by this government
against the effect that it was having on
on on biodiversity what were we doing in
my own brief i have to say just looking
at what i would be doing we have this
30 years ago
our government as one of many signed up
to an investment charter on energy and
this investment charter was from another
age but essentially it's being used by
energy companies to challenge sovereign
nations who are doing their best to get
to net zero so we're seeing countries
like italy like the netherlands who have
a policy to to get rid of carbon from
there from the atmosphere of being
challenged by coal companies saying
you're not allowed to undermine our
profits now so what does that do about
it is changing and well that charter
needs changing and some countries are
saying that they want to change it but
britain is still sitting on the fence so
just from my own brief it just shows
that we are not really leading by
example
um the rich country said uh at paris
that what they try to do is to put
together a fund of 100 billion i talked
a little earlier in this programme to
tina stegy from the marshall islands who
was very polite about it but looked
pretty
hacked off about the fact that almost
none of that i mean a very small amount
of that money seems to have actually
been pledged um how much would we should
we be putting into that
we should be putting in the amount that
we promised i mean nations turned up at
paris made pledges they get the fanfare
they get their headlines and then the
money doesn't isn't available it's the
same as you know developing countries
are pretty hacked off when it comes to
vaccines when we make all these promises
to be to be ensuring that they get
access to vaccines and we still haven't
done that either you know we're not
going to be
even on the plans now as has changed the
vaccines are not going to be available
to the develo developing world until way
into next year this is not good enough
uh brutally put i mean
it is not your habit to agree on
anything with the prime minister but he
has been rather gloomy this week um
brutally put um
you're sort of in the same camp as he is
aren't you that you think that we are
quite a long way from getting an
agreement that we need
i would really like to see the prime
minister use such statesmanship as he
has
um to put all effort into glasgow
it is not all lost but we really do need
to be serious about it this is not a
giant photo opportunity we cannot spend
our time green washing nations we have
to be truthful about how big a problem
this is how far we have to go
and we have to make sure that there is
some serious commitments made not just
by us but by other countries and boris
johnson has to summon up all
statesmanship as he has
to be able to fulfill the role of
leadership which britain needs to be
doing at this time
emily thornberry thank you very much
indeed
let's turn away from cop here in glasgow
and the g20 meeting in rome to something
a bit different to finish this programme
to mark the end of black history month
which is today i sat down to talk with
the government equalities minister
kemi badanok is never far from
controversy in a brief that seems to
attract it she both enthuses and enrages
i spoke to her before kathleen stock
resigned from sussex university and the
government published its proposals on
so-called gay conversion therapy
minister this is the last day of what
people call black history month um
what have you seen this month that you
liked and what have you seen that you
didn't like
um
i've seen a lot of very interesting um
sort of talks that people have given
about black history i haven't attended
them but i know that they've been
they've been happening and i'm really
pleased that people are thinking more
about black contributions to british
history so i've liked that
um what i haven't liked maybe perhaps uh
interventions that seem more contrived
perhaps because
certain organizations feel that this is
something they need to do so they do it
but
not necessarily in the meaningful in a
way that i think is meaningful or shows
that they are are interested in it and
to be honest i think black history month
it's become much bigger than it used to
be
because a lot of people are doing
different things different things with
it it's an american it's an american
import which hasn't always fitted
exactly with what i would call british
and commonwealth commonwealth history
but um what i'm also seeing is there's
politicization happening in every sphere
and i see it happening even there where
um
black history month becomes racism
history month which isn't what it should
be it should be a time for us to come
together and look at contributions which
haven't always uh
been taught because
they are you know they might be seen as
very niche or they're just not
traditionally what people thought should
be in the curriculum
is your point that um
what we call black history month is in a
sense become white racism history month
i think i think that's that's that's the
way to put it and i remember last year i
was absolutely horrified i said this in
a speech in parliament my seven-year-old
came home from school and said we're
doing black history
in this uh in school because every other
month is white history and i was
absolutely appalled by that that is not
what it's supposed to be black history
is british history it's history that
every black or white person or asian
person should be interested in it's not
something specially carved out
particularly worrying for my daughter
who is mixed race where she is being
taught that this is a special kind of
history that's different for her and i
don't want her to have this sort of um
sort of split identity i i think it's
not helpful for people to look at uh
communities as being so separate we
should be looking at what brings us all
together
you were reported as saying that you
were
less concerned about colonialism
than some other people might be
surely um
slavery and colonialism are pretty big
mountains in the history
of
most black or many black people in this
country they are they are but they are
also one of many many things that affect
um that affect black people across the
world and the context of that
conversation was actually talking about
nigeria it wasn't talking about this
country and if you go to nigeria and
talk about colonialism but certainly
from the part i come from america person
people who say well comic book
colonialism and basically that means why
is that why is colonialism my concern
and that's because the debate in that
country has moved on to contemporary
issues so yes colonialism is a fact it
is something that happened but you look
at what's happening in nigeria at the
moment with extreme islamic terrorism
with the value of the currency
completely um being uh decimated with
the economy not doing well there was a
really interesting article in the
economist about about nigeria those are
the things which concern nigerians today
and as a first generation immigrant my
family still live there those are the
things that i'm very interested in
talking about and there's also a more
important point around this that when we
focus on the things that have gone wrong
uh in the past you know certain elements
we also stop thinking about the things
that make countries successful white
people don't have to talk about the
crimean war or the suez canal and so on
why is it that when it comes to black
people we are again restricted to
specific topics which we need to
demonstrate that we are correct or
saying the right things um on those
things and why is it that a debate which
you can have
very easily and an opinion that is
actually more popular in nigeria that
colonialism is not the root of its
problems it's something that cannot be
said in the uk i think that's an
interesting question well
let's
let's look at that
is that really true that people would
say in nigeria now colonialism isn't
that it doesn't matter but it's not that
big a deal when for example nigeria is
itself
uh
a consequence
of a colonial division of africa i mean
nobody in their right mind would
naturally
put
yoruba yeah and igbo
in the same country that was a
consequence of colonialism yes and
nigeria's more recent history is
completely shaped by that you can't
really say colonial doesn't matter
because nigeria wouldn't exist that
wouldn't exist without colonialism but
that's not what they say
if in fact that is the biggest issue
when you look at and i'm straight into
into foreign affairs now that is the
country and the way it has been
constituted workable i think that's what
um was alluded to in that economist
article i think we need to look at those
things that do make countries well run
looking again at
free trade looking at free markets
having very strong rule of law
property rights all of those things
those are the things that people should
be talking about now it's not saying
that colonialism had no impact or it
doesn't even have a lasting impact but
what can we do about the problems that a
country faces today and i think that's
where the argument should be and there
are many other people who are having the
debate about race and colonialism i
don't think that that's wrong but why
should i be forced to have their
opinions there is something changing in
the way that we in the way that we have
debates in society now that it isn't
about different opinions it's about
allowed opinions and unallowed um
opinions i'm often reading about how i'm
under fire you know when officials bring
they ring a newspaper articles against
minister under fire uh for saying this i
really am i under fire i don't feel
under fire and then they show me some
very angry people on twitter who i
haven't actually taken any notice of
black lives matter movement had a huge
global impact
broadly speaking
a good thing or not a good thing
um i think with
the phrase black lives matter very much
a good thing
we have been able to focus a lot on
where there's discrimination in society
or across the globe even where there are
disparities what is causing those
disparities there's a lot of work in
government um which we've been doing in
order to find out uh what is causing
differences in outcomes and what we can
do about them i think that that has been
a good thing
where it has become a vehicle for
smuggling in other themes
probably less so because those many of
those things are not values which i
share but
that doesn't mean that it should be
stopped or banned you know i believe in
freedom of speech and freedom of
expression it's a different um
it's often quite uh when you look at the
you know defund the police and other
things the people who claim to speak for
that movement uh
what those things that they put forward
or they purport i do disagree with those
things i don't think those are these are
good things but in terms of focusing on
how we can improve disparities and
reduce prejudice and discrimination yes
you have um responsibility for the
health equalities brief we've been
talking about race but of course one of
the hot issues right now is trans
uh what people call trans rights and
that's been
become an issue partly because of what
people can
can say without being contested or
cancelled or whatever
the right expression is
the big example recently has been that
of
kathleen stock at sussex university who
it is thought may lose her position
because she is what's called a gender
critical feminist i.e she believes
in the biological reality of sex where
do you stand on this so on kathleen
stock i was appalled at the way that she
was treated and in fact i i went to
sussex university and i tweeted when i
saw the university statement backing her
nobody should face bullying or
harassment in the workplace that is
actually another thing that the um that
the equality act looks at uh bullying
and harassment i don't think she should
lose her job and i think that she has
every right to hold the beliefs which
she does i think she is probably in step
with the majority of the population
and what we in government are trying to
do is show that we do believe um that
trans people should be free to live
their lives as they wish but where
people see a conflict and that conflict
has tended to be around single sex
spaces and um where the gender reassign
and the definition of gender
reassignment and how uh gender critical
feminists as they are known believe that
those rights are in conflict what we can
do in order to
provide clarity so the government
position is that
we will do everything we can to support
trans uh people in particular all lgbt
people but trans people in particular
when it comes to health care because
they have different health care needs
from other lgbt people however we do not
think that that goes as far as self id
we do believe that there should be a
process to get a gender recognition
certificate
rather than for people and the process
does mean involving medical
professionals as well
some trans activists would say that the
fact that you do not accept the
statement that trans women are women is
in itself a form of violence you are
what is called a turf a trans
trans exclusionary radical feminist i i
think it's sad that the the debate has
turned into one of name calling what i
would ask people to do is actually look
at what the policies are what it is
we're doing in order to protect people
of all types
whether they are lgbt
uh of different race racial backgrounds
uh the different sexes we are a
government that believes in equality and
fairness for all and everything we're
doing is to make sure that we have a an
equal society and we should not get to a
point where having a different opinion
becomes a reason to insult other people
that's absolutely wrong
well that's some kind of first for
television the government minister
speaking yoruba on air well that's it
from us this morning from glasgow but
stick with us because in a moment we'll
be assessing as usual what we've heard
and it's possible that in the next half
hour we'll also hear live from prince
charles
will it be a good cop or will it be a
bad cop who knows well tell you who
probably sam coats and he's going to be
joining me for trevor phillips the take
[Music]